foreign
[Music]
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story 28 Days of Horror the
villagers captured starved and tortured
now preparing to testify in Ukraine's
biggest ever war crimes trial look at
the size of this cell no windows and out
of the 19 nine of them were children
we hear from children haunted by fears
of execution and see new 3D technology
being used to collect evidence against
Russian soldiers
also tonight's a grieving family returns
to the scene of the crime in Nottingham
as a 31 year old man is charged with
murder
in Greece a tearful reunion but the
United Nations says 500 other migrants
have feared dead after their boat
capsized
the former boss of the police Watchdog
is charged with raping a girl aged under
16.
a national crisis while the number of
children missing school has doubled
since the pandemic
plus we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
foreign
good evening they were forced to
underground as children and emerged
after 28 Days of Horror as adults
several teenagers and some toddlers are
among more than 300 residents of a
village in Northern Ukraine held captive
by Russian forces in a school basement
during the early days of the war starved
terrified and tortured they had no air
and minimal hygiene their evidence will
be Central to the biggest war crimes
trial since Russia invaded a case which
could end up in the international
criminal court Sky special correspondent
Alex Crawford has had rare access to
survivors and prosecutors and sent this
exclusive report from yahidne
democracy
from the bombed out ruins of their
Community Club the survivors of one of
the most horrifying acts in this war
singing Lusty Defiance
The Villages of yahidne are about to be
the star Witnesses in Ukraine's biggest
war crimes trial to date
they fall silent
[Music]
they're honoring those who didn't make
it through the largest single kidnapping
carried out by Russian troops during
their invasion of the country
the memories of what they've all been
through are still searingly raw
in the basement of the Village School
Russian soldiers held hostage almost the
entire community
Ivan was amongst nearly 400 villagers
held captive underground here for nearly
a month
the picture taken on their release shows
one of the bigger cells packed full of
hostages they were crammed in like this
all the time starved terrified and
tortured
368 villagers in all 69 of them children
they were split up amongst a network of
different sized cells with no hygiene
little air and just buckets to go to the
toilet in with all the rooms horribly
overcrowded
they put numbers on the outside of the
room there were 19 in here and look at
the size of this cell no windows and out
of the 19 nine of them were children
there was no room to lie down or sleep
properly
no war the words say the children Drew
themselves with unhappy faces amongst
hopeful hearts and Ukrainian flags and
there are others showing executions that
they feared or witnessed few thought
they'd get out alive
it was really scary for the children and
grandchildren it was like a nightmare I
don't know how it got through it
Russian soldiers set up camp inside The
Village's only school days after the
invasion began the Big Sandy scars on
the school grounds are where they dug in
their military vehicles
schools like hospitals are protected
under international law and hiding
inside to launch attacks is considered a
war crime
we've been given rare access to what the
Ukrainian prosecutors found whole
military files a soldiers backpack
phones and SIM cards as well as
commanders orders
they've identified 15 Russian soldiers
that they believe violated the
international rules of War When They
carried out the siege in yehydney school
we're trying to prove that this large
number of people over 360. were kept in
the basement of a school and used by the
Russian troops as human Shields against
the Ukrainian forces and they're
confident they have the physical
evidence left behind by the soldiers
there are also hundreds of witnesses
who'll testify about the brutal
conditions which led to at least 10 of
the hostages dying with their bodies
left there sometimes for days
some of the children kept underground in
the dark amongst the corpses were babies
or toddlers
others like Marina and Lilia were young
teenagers when they were held captive
we went down there as children Marina
says and we left as adults with a very
different view about everything
Ukrainian forensic investigators showed
us the new technological devices which
they're hoping will seal a guilty
verdict in the courts
they've taken thousands of images using
for the first time in the country a
range of 3D scanners to document what
happened inside
it's an incredible technological weapon
which freezes the crime scene forever so
forensic analysts lawyers and police can
minutely examine and zoom in on every
part of the investigation site all
Village was a hostage it'll also be used
by the international criminal court to
prosecute those responsible
I want to hear the first verdicts this
year Natalia tells us that's what I want
and it's the wish of millions of
ukrainians too there's much unresolved
anguish over just what happened in
yehydney and a lot of Hope being pinned
on the upcoming war crimes trial to
avenge everything they went through and
those who perished Alex Crawford Sky
News and yahidna in Northern Ukraine
well as prosecutors prepare their war
crimes case in Saint Petersburg a
defiant Vladimir Putin warned that
Ukraine would soon run out of its own
military equipment he was speaking at a
business Forum the Russian president
saying Kiev had no choice but to depend
on Weaponry from elsewhere and the
Western tanks were already burning on
the front line tomorrow he'll meet a
delegation of African leaders as part of
a peace Mission that's after they
visited Kiev which was being targeted by
a volley of missiles described by
Ukrainian officials as a greeting from
Russia
back here a 31 year old man who's been
charged with the murders of Grace
O'Malley Kumar Barnaby Weber and Ian
Coates in Nottingham valdo calacani will
appear in court tomorrow also accused of
three counts of attempted murder after
attacks across the city in the early
hours of Tuesday morning Lisa Dowd
reports
this family clearly find comfort in
being in this city this is the exact
spot in Nottingham where their 19 year
old son Barnaby Weber lost his life
as police held traffic back they laid
flowers on the road where he died
31 year old valdo calacani of no fixed
address is charged with the murders of
Barnaby fellow student Grace O'Malley
Kumar and school caretaker Ian Coates
they were stabbed to death on Tuesday
also studied in this city he left the
University of Nottingham last summer
after graduating from a course in
mechanical engineering he's due to
appear before magistrates on Saturday
kalikarni's family vicar in West Wales
said his thoughts were with the victims
it just it was overwhelming to think
that lives have just been cut down like
that so horrifically and so our hearts
went out to the victims and we were
praying for them the three victims who
all loved sport were remembered on day
one of the ashes the biggest day in
cricket started with a moment's silence
and to commemorate Barnaby and Grace
both talented cricketers during the 56th
over the number on Barnaby's Cricket
shirt Amazing Grace was played from the
stands
[Music]
in Nottingham's Market Square the mass
of flowers just grows
well I just think it's it's so cruel and
so harsh I don't even know what
did I thought I should come and also be
part of the community morning also on
people's minds here are the three others
who were run over during these attacks
two are in a stable condition and one
has been discharged from hospital
kalikarni is also charged with their
attempted murders
this week has ended three lives and
changed countless others here it is the
week this city will never forget
Lisa Dowd Sky News Nottingham
the United Nations says 500 people are
missing after an overcrowded fishing
boat carrying migrants capsized in the
Mediterranean Sea so far no women or
children have been rescued it's feared
they were trapped on the lower deck when
the boat sank Sky News has heard the
harrowing account of one man who
described swimming to safety through
water filled with bodies well the ship
reportedly set off for Italy from the
Libyan Port City of tobrook around a
week ago it sank in the early hours of
Wednesday morning leading to questions
for the Greek Coast Guard who's changed
their account of the tragedy our Middle
East correspondent Alistar bunkel
reports from Kalamata where the
survivors were brought to shore
there's been little if any good news for
three days but this morning a man who'd
flown to Greece to search for his
relative found him alive
but there are still so many missing as
many as 500 the United Nations estimates
and everyone is looking for someone
we've been told stories of passengers
drinking their own urine and sucking
liquid from melting refrigerators on
board because water ran out early into
the Crossing
Greek social workers say they've heard
horrific accounts from some of the
survivors they've been looking after
while visiting the hospital yesterday
the story that shocked me the most at
least from the hospital was that of a
man describing to us how he managed to
be rescued from the boat
he said that for two hours he was
swimming among the bodies of children
there is now a focus on the Greek Coast
Guard and questions about their actions
on the night people are starting to ask
why they didn't intervene when it was
obvious that the boat was dangerously
overcrowded there were migrants on board
and therefore almost certainly people
Smugglers too
at first the Coast Guard said that they
hadn't thrown a rope to the boat now
they admit that they did
a local lawyer says the authorities
might have questions to answer
the ship is obviously in danger there
are just too many refugees on board
which is something that is obvious with
those in charge but despite that they
throw food and water instead of throwing
life jackets rescue vessels rescue boats
the search operation is now entering its
final hours they found nothing and no
one since Wednesday morning
this is the warehouse in the port of
Kalamata where they brought the
survivors
looked off and gave him food and water
but they've now all gone they've been
bussed to an immigration processing
center elsewhere in Central Greece and
so this is now empty and I think
significantly the aid agencies have also
left
they are not expecting to receive any
more survivors
guide news film these pictures of
migrants waiting to cross to Europe from
the Libyan Port of to Brook this week
it's become a major hub for smuggling
operations and it's the same port that
the boat left from before its fateful
end off the coast of Greece
nine Egyptians have been arrested by
Greek authorities on suspicion of people
smuggling they'll appear in court on
Monday
Sky News in southern Greece
foreign
ahead of the police Watchdog which
investigates officers conduct has been
charged with raping a child Michael
Lockwood has strenuously denied the
allegations that Shaman Freeman Powell
is here with me um these allegations
date back a few decades yes that's right
so it's nine offenses that's six counts
of indecent assault and three counts of
rape and it dates back to October 1985
through to March 1986 so almost 40 years
ago in the now uh 64 year old Michael
Lockwood would have been in his 20s and
he's been alleged to have raped a child
under the age of 16 and as you say this
is a man that was the former head of the
independent office for police conduct
who's now facing some very serious
allegations himself but it is important
to stress that his lawyers have said
that he's strenuously denies all of the
allegations facing him and that he will
be strongly defending himself while
still cooperating thing with proceedings
and he is due to appear at the
magistrates Court in Hull on June the
28th okay Sherman thank you
a truck driver has been found guilty of
killing 11 people at a synagogue in
Pittsburgh in 2018. jurors must now
decide whether Robert Bowers will be
sentenced to life in prison without
parole or be sentenced to death that
deliberation is expected to take several
weeks
the boss of Tesco says there are
encouraging signs that inflation is
starting to ease as he hit back at
critics who've blamed supermarkets for
high food prices the bank of England
some politicians and unions have all
Accused at the grocery sector of
profiteering but Tesco chief executive
Ken Murphy says they've already seen
reductions in the price of milk bread
and pasta
Boris Johnson has committed a fresh
breach of the ministerial code with his
new role as Economist for the Daily Mail
the advisory committee on business
appointments says the former prime
minister only told them of the
appointment half an hour before making
the News public
Charlie is 13 years old each morning his
Nan places his uniform at the end of his
bed and each morning Charlie refuses to
get dressed he is one of more than a
hundred thousand children missing school
regularly each year a number which has
doubled since the pandemic our people
and politics correspondent Nick Martin
reports now on what's being described as
a national crisis
thirteen-year-old Charlie has spent just
a handful of days in school in the last
three years and often the school run
ends like this
all right come on
let's go
try don't start this
Charlie's Heroes
but don't get upset come on
because I can't do anything
you can do it what we witness takes us
to the heart of a national crisis of
School attendance fueled by the pandemic
Charlie's bright he's got lots of
friends and reports suggests when he's
in school he works hard and behaves but
he still refuses to go
everyone when Anne comes in and she
tries to get me up I'm like nope not
doing it and then keeps getting mad at
me and then she keeps coming in and
saying Charlie get your clothes on I'm
saying nope what is it about school that
you're not keen on the people the
teachers the classes
the uniform
Charlie's school have offered a reduced
timetable and learning in isolation but
it doesn't seem to have worked we've
dragged him in the car crying dad's even
lifted him out of a van at one point to
put him in the gate and he just lost his
Rag and ended up punching a wall
you know Charlie's not alone there are
thousands and thousands of children just
like him missing chunks of their
education
the numbers are staggering in the first
term of this Academic Year more than 125
000 pupils just like Charlie spent more
time out of class than in it that's
doubled since the pandemic
we've been given rare access to a
special team whose job it is to get
children back to class after the school
lockdowns during the pandemic I've
worked for the council in this area for
23 years now and this is literally the
busiest we've ever been
been shut in your home for nearly years
and then trying to get back out again
and get back into the systems they were
in historically it's a massive change of
habit that there was lost social skills
there was lots of confidence there's
some anxiety and some of it has crept
Beyond anxiety into mental health issues
Charlie shares a love of boxing with his
dad James who says he's tried everything
to get his son into school but he's
frustrated too at what he sees as a
rigid curriculum that fails to inspire
his son the way he looks he's doing
lessons that he doesn't need for his
future plans do you agree I do agree
with that I think people should be
pushed really into what they really want
to do not just sitting down in science
or stuff that they don't need for the
future but James has already been fined
thousands of pounds for Charlie's
absence and he says the next time it
could be much worse
I think the next step was behind bars
from what I was on Prison yeah and how
do you feel about that well if if it
means he's not hurting himself and stuff
like I'd rather do it all day long
before what's all James you'd actually
rather go to prison
your son going to school yeah to see my
son that's not going to school
the actual mechanics of it isn't it the
physical the physical trauma that he
goes through and mental trauma he goes
through then yeah my son's obviously
without a question
obviously no one said that in prison
just because they ain't going to school
that's that's stupid but
I just like school so much that if my
dad did go to prison I'd still refuse
because of how much I dislike it
the government says it's committed to
getting children like Charlie back to
school by rolling out what it calls
attendance hubs with mentors to help
children in the worst affected areas but
it seems far from getting the numbers
back to pre-pandemic levels
Charlie's day ends with him not going to
school his story though offers a
snapshot into the lives of thousands of
other children struggling with the very
concept of school falling behind on
their education as each day passes Nick
Martin Sky News Blackpool
the U.S justice department has found
that Minneapolis Police repeatedly
discriminated against black people and
Native Americans the findings of a
two-year civil rights investigation
which was prompted by the killing of
George Floyd claimed systemic problems
made his death possible
we found that MPD and the City of
Minneapolis engages in a pattern or
practice of using excessive force
unlawfully discriminating against black
and Native American people in
enforcement activities
violating the rights of people engaged
in protected speech
and discriminating against people with
behavioral disabilities
a house pipe ban will be introduced in
Kent and Sussex in 10 days time due to
high demand for drinking water some
residents across the region have been
left with little or no water forcing
schools to Close Southeast water said
demand was at record levels
and the runs flowed for England on day
one of the ashes Joe root made 118 in
England's total of 393 for eight
declared Australia closed on 14 without
use
up for years they were the objects of
teenage Obsession fast forward 30 years
and take that and their fans have of
course grown up but the Nostalgia
inspired by the music has never weighed
in fact it's now being played out on
screen as our arts and entertainment
correspondent Katie Spencer reports
[Music]
[Applause]
one of the biggest boy bands of the 90s
still going but five are now three
tighten your bra straps girls this is
the next incarnation of take that of
Phil
[Applause]
I mean as I take that fan to the
greatest day of my life being here join
in if you know the words but with female
friendship the focus sadly someone had
to break the news to Gary that he wasn't
going to have a new career in acting
with this a huge blunder in my opinion
but anyway we go on we go on actually
you still and they're biggest fan of the
whole entire world Steve instead
comedian Ashling B plays a Competition
winner who bags four tickets to see her
teenage crush's reform for a concert in
Athens I've come a long way come a long
way but we're not too sure where you've
been okay thanks again just do seven
minutes
oh was it sort of gloriously good fun
for you guys to be in the streets and
Performing some of these they're long
days never forget we did a Conga 30
times down the road that scene took two
or three days of rehearsals so we hope
it looks easy but it never actually is
behind the scenes from fantasies of
marrying the boys through to the ritual
recording of top of the pops it's
certainly a mamma mia-esque Nostalgia
trip did you witness some some sights in
the 90s
oh yeah unfortunately they're not very
you know I can't really mention them on
camera you know and within a year we
were traveling around to all these crazy
countries uh just having the time of our
lives and and that's how it felt that's
how I remember the 90s being
um I remember being you know just noise
chaos screaming it was just terrific it
was it was a crazy time but the
experiences
I've had through the band have been
incredible you know and now I'm here
I've got a film now
spotting how and where the band make a
very brief Cameo is the challenge in a
feel-good movie that celebrates all the
joy and awkwardness of teenage Obsession
in the 90s Katie Spencer Sky News
I think Katie might be a bit of a fan
don't you uh and that was Sky News uh 10
now coming up shortly before King
Charles is first trooping the color
since his coronation find out which
Community Champions and British greats
have been recognized in his birthday
honors list I'll tell you about that in
a few minutes and of course also coming
up we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
papers that's in the Press preview
including this story it's on the front
of tomorrow's Guardian the headline Tory
time bombers Millions face surge in
mortgage rates there it is and tonight
I'll be joined by the guardian columnist
Zoe Williams and also former
conservative MP turn chief executive of
the charity business in the community
Mary McLeod don't go away
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
hello again you're watching Sky News in
just a moment the Press preview a first
look at what is on tomorrow's front
pages but first our top stories Sky News
has had rare access to Ukrainian
prosecutors preparing for the country's
biggest war crimes trial after hundreds
of villages were kept underground and
used as human Shields by Russian forces
police investigating the Nottingham
attacks have charged a 31 year old man
with three counts of murder and three
counts of attempted murder
and the UN says it believes as many as
500 people may still be missing after a
boat carrying migrants sank off the
coast of Greece
so we've got the Press preview for you
in a moment but first they are the
community Champions and The Best of
British honored by the king in his first
birthday honors since his coronation
among them an internationally renowned
magazine editor a campaigning dancer and
one woman who lost three members of her
family to violence our Royal
correspondent Laura bundock has been
meeting some of the honorees
who gets gongs after the blasting of
Boris Johnson's resignation honors
perhaps here a less contentious lineup
that's lovely fantastic recognized and
rewarded in the King's first birthday
honors Suzanne Richards now MBE he lost
her son Joel her brother and her father
in the 2015 Tunisian terror attack and
she set up a charity to help others
bereaved by murder or terrorism
never in a in a world of Sunday does it
ever think I'd get anything like this
but it is Bittersweet yeah there's a
reason why I've received this Suzanne is
already poised to help the families of
last week's Nottingham killings just
knowing what that families know what
those families are going through
um and you know it's just terrific
there's such a mirror image of what
happened they were 19 Joel was 19
student University Savage Joel so yeah
but we will be here to support them
at 18 junior frude is the youngest on
the list awarded a British Empire medal
the young dancer making moves to beat
bullying with his hashtag Boys Can Dance
it means so much like it just shows like
all the hard work I do is being noticed
and like my voice is being heard and
people are hearing me and it just feels
so crazy that I'm the youngest like it's
it's so crazy and I'm so honored to
receive this award also on the list Dame
Anna Wintour the Vogue editor-in-chief
awarded a companion of Honor as are the
author sir Ian McEwen and Professor Sir
John Bell who played a prominent role in
the pandemic there are mbes for Davina
McCall and the actor Vicky McClure who's
campaigned about dementia and an mbe2
for the footballer now pundit Ian Wright
for his services to charity and Sport
this year's list a continuation of the
coronation theme of helping out and
service the king doesn't choose who gets
honored but it is part of his first
official birthday celebrations including
his first trooping the color as king he
will make his way up the mail on
horseback the first time a Monarch's
done that since 1986.
and for that the flags are out and the
route ready with thousands expected for
another Royal spectacle Laura bundock
Sky News
foreign
we'll be discussing some of those honors
a bit later in the Press preview it is
our first look at what is on tomorrow's
front pages and we'll be checking out
the headlines tonight with Guardian
columnist Zoe Williams who's joined by
the former conservative Peter and chief
executive of the charity business in the
community Mary McLeod they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight a
very good evening to both of you we
shall chat in a moment after we've had a
look at some of those front pages
certainly the ones that have arrived
here at Sky the mirror leading with the
King's first birthday honors list and
says unlike Boris Johnson's these are
truly deserved
Boris it's a fast don't back me reach
the front of the express as it reports
the former prime minister has urged his
supporters to move on and not oppose the
deranged Commons sanction
the eye claims that High Street banks
are making billions during the cost of
living crisis by increasing mortgages
without passing on interest rates to
Savers while the guardian also looks to
an expected surge in mortgages which
they say make the Tories a time bomb
and the Daily Mail reports that the
first host pipe ban of the year has been
slapped on those living in Kent and
Sussex and don't forget scan that QR
code that you see on screen during the
program and you'll be able to have a
look at the front pages of the papers
while you're watching us discussing them
and to do that Guardian columnist say
Williams and former conservative mp10
chief executive of the charity business
in the community Mary McLeod a very good
evening to both of you a humid warm
evening but good of you to uh go inside
and speak to us tonight let's start with
the eyes shall we
um it's miserable reading for the
weekend this isn't it UK mortgage
rip-off Banks pocketing billions by
hiking up mortgages but not doing the
same Zoe for savings accounts
and it's absolutely right to call Banks
out on
Behavior like this because they are
it's you know it's like the shopkeeper
who always shortchanges you they're
they're raising greets when it suits
them and not raising rates when it
doesn't suit them the problem is that it
doesn't get close to what an actual
absolute catastrophe this is for the
British consumer stroke homeowner stroke
saver stroke citizen right because even
if they did hike savings rates most
people of working age do not have
significant savings at the moment so it
wouldn't make a huge amount of
difference and it wouldn't do anything
to mitigate the cost of living crisis it
wouldn't do anything to mitigate the
mortgage crisis so even
we are calling for kind of fairness in
this in these strength and times it's
still not going to touch the sides
unless we I you know we either get
permanently used to much higher interest
rates which will cause a housing crash
if there isn't if one isn't in train
already or
I don't know some hand of God comes in
um and redistributes the housing market
but the idea that Banks could actually
just you know rebalance everything by
putting an extra two percent on savings
is fanciful yeah Mary you know a lot
about a common economics and how
business works is it fair to say that
the banks or the big lenders are
exploiting customers
well I mean certainly on this I mean
when people come out of fixed mortgage
rates which I think this is what this is
looking at and lots of people will be
hugely worried about about this as they
finish their fixed rate mortgage term
and they go on to more variable rates
and therefore they will be aligned to
what the the base rate is
um set of course by the bank of England
um so it's I mean Banks need to respond
to this and they don't have any control
over what the base rate um that the bank
of England says
um but they do have some you know
ability to adapt while the how they set
their interest rates beyond that
um on mortgage and what they offer for
mortgages so you're at a time of cost
living and there's many businesses
including banks have been trying to help
people during cost of living crisis but
this is one where when they see this
headline I think hopefully it will give
them time to reflect and and try and do
something different because it really is
important for people
um who will just end up defaulting on
their mortgages and then it just becomes
an even worse crisis so and it's got the
thinking has to be done now before that
happens yeah so do you think do you
think there needs to be some sort of um
competition inquiry in into all of this
some MPS are asking for it
well look I mean I'm really happy
whenever there's kind of profiteering
going on I'm really happy to see it it
investigated but the truth is you know
if you look at something like energy
crisis for instance and the unbelievable
astronomical profits that energy
companies are making which even against
the backdrop of the war in Ukraine the
you know the sanctions on Russian gas
even against that backdrop their profits
are unreasonable and you can bet that
when price when wholesale prices come
down your actual bills won't come down
for some time after it now that I can
completely see the justification for
investigating but mortgages they're
pretty competitive they track the bank
of England base rate
um and they compete with each other to
track it most closely so if they could
give you a mortgage under the base rate
then they then one of them would and
then another one of them would what's
going on here is the interest rates are
being used as an attempt to keep
inflation down they're not working the
reason they're not working is is
actually many fold but
somebody at the bank of England should
take into account the fact that raising
interest rates is not being effective at
cutting inflation and stop raising
interest rates
um you're married I mean it's the same
store on the front of the Guardian with
obviously a slightly different take
Story Time bombers Millions face surgeon
in mortgage rates
um the 13th time that the interest rate
is going to go up in a row uh next week
now clearly the tour is hope that
inflation is going to start coming down
by the end of the year but according to
the guardian that's not necessarily
going to be the case and it's going to
be a real issue as a conservative for
the conservatives the voters go to the
polls
yeah absolutely and they've got a point
here I mean UK Finance who's the the
banking trade body
um as I was warned about this and the
numbers offers 2.4 million they're
saying fixed rate mortgage clicks are in
between now and the end of next year so
that's a lot of people affected by by
this and so therefore will come into the
the territory of general election time
and where a the government will be will
will naturally will people will look to
them say what did you do about it what
have you done to try and resolve this at
times of Crisis I mean this reminds me
of the 2008 financial prizes where where
you know
there's so many issues with individuals
the impact individuals and and
entrepreneurs as well small businesses
and and some of the behaviors then in
banking were held to accountant and and
this is where customers and zoom is is
right there I mean its customers can
vote with their feet and what we need is
some banks to be really creative
Innovative around now and say you know
actually we're going to do things
differently we believe in in supporting
customers and in hard times and let's do
things in a different way that will mean
that they will see that they are valued
as customers and because it's much
easier now to to move around Banks than
than before so yeah it's customers need
to input their you know really decide
and and do something if they can yeah
okay uh let's move on to the front of
the mail uh we're going to talk about
their new uh star columnist I wonder who
it could be it's not very clear is it
from the front of the mail
um uh but the first but the the headline
we're going to talk about before the
break uh host pipe band Zoe it's here
already it's not even officially summer
till next week
I mean it's really hard to see where the
Daily Mail is going with a story between
talking about summer talking about water
companies and talking about you know the
the kind of
outrageous perpetrated against the Great
British Gardener they seem to be trying
to celebrate and be outraged at the same
time which I guess is their happy place
you know that's something that's what
they're into it's
for whatever the mismanagement of water
companies and we've had so many sewage
stories recently and so many stories
about the their failure to invest
they're completely astronomical
shareholder dividends they're you know
the fact that whichever way you cut it
the taxpayer always pays
um
all of that being said if they've put a
hose pipe ban in place it's because
there's a drought so if I personally
find it a little bit difficult to get
exercised about
okay uh let's see if Mary is exercised
about the front of the Daily Express the
headline Boris it's a farce don't back
me this is the announcement that Boris
Johnson has told his supporters not to
oppose uh the votes on Monday he says
it's time to turn the temperature down
um what what's his thinking here Mary
I mean I think the the Privileges
Committee in the House of Commons there
the vote will be on Monday in the
Commons on the report that they did and
the the recent few days you know there
was lots of words going around about hey
the what would happen and and I think so
I think hopefully this might try and
calm things down I mean at the end of
the day it is a committee that's set up
um and if uh and you know if you if they
didn't like the the approach of the
committee then probably that should be
done right at the start of it
um but the former prime minister is now
just trying to distance himself from us
I think by a also announcing the new job
which which it gives it gives people
something else to think about but uh but
yes the the votes will go ahead in
Monday I think it's potentially a
one-line whip so I'm not sure how many
will actually be there to to vote but a
but I would imagine that the vote will
probably go all through to support the
Privileges committee which has been set
up for the reason of the scrutiny that
they've done so
um calling free supporters to to back
down I mean he's not doing that as a
kind gesture to Richie sunac is he
I mean I think that he that the entire
idea was silly right so when the
um privileges committee dropped their
report on Thursday morning there was
that weird surge Boris Johnson wrote
1700 words in frankly columnist ease it
wasn't a tall X Prime ministerial it
what didn't even really sound like a
politician he sounded like a columnist
um and you know he made all kinds of
weird slurs against members of the
committee he referred to the fact that
Bernard Jenkins used to be a naturist he
called Harry a Harman rude names I mean
he didn't even actually now I think
about it right like a telegraph
columnist he wrote more like a kind of
um you know an Express columnist it was
very intemperate his language
um I don't know whether he then asked
his supporters to come out fighting on
social media telling other Tori MPS that
if they didn't vote down the committee
his report that they could be deselected
by their local constituency parties or
whether his hardcore of supporters are
now so extreme and sort of crack
themselves that they just were doing
that as on a kind of freelance basis and
there were if you remember only a
handful of them it was Jacob Reese
Margaret with Maddie and Doris and it
was like three other people
um it even if there had been 50 Tory MPS
saying we're backing Boris we're going
to vote against this report they still
wouldn't have had a hope of voting it
down they still would wouldn't really
have had a hope of forcing Rishi Suna to
call a general election and they
definitely wouldn't have had a hope of
getting Boris into pole position in some
other kind of guys
um so that he would be a realistic
election Prospect so I think probably
he's he's called the dogs off but I'm
not sure who called the dogs on yeah
okay that's a that's a that's a very
interesting take on it um what you've
mentioned the columns are going let's
talk about it very quickly before the
break uh Mary
it's not about party gate or honors or
quitting as an MP it's about losing
weight
yes and um and then very important thing
I must say too I've spent my whole life
in a diet but yes it's all about the 11
30 p.m reading the fridge which I must
admit I do know something about uh but
yeah this he's probably trying to stay
away from politics for at least this
column and uh and focus on something
that actually a lot of people will will
sort of sympathize on which is about
weight except what they've done here is
talk about the the ex the the drug the
the semi glutamate drug there whether
it's sex and that we go via same package
there's a range of them he's obviously
seen two of his colleagues shed lots of
pounds and and wondered how they'd done
it and
um but I yes some some GPS are giving
prescriptions for some aren't so
obviously Boris has someone that does a
but it has been approved to be to be
used that's supposed to reduce
um your appetite but yeah I think Boris
has gone back to exercise and and will
pass so so whether other people are
trying to rent into fasting the five two
protein only there's a whole range of
things out there and at the end of the
day it's probably it's probably simple
maths of reducing the the bad stuff you
you put in and then getting as much
exercise as possible but yeah these
these weight loss drugs that appetite
suppressants
um are available but they're expensive
behind um behind the chemist counter
yeah Zoe I'm sure you've got lots to say
about the the column I'm going to save
it till uh look at your nodding I'm
going to save it till uh the next hour
if you don't mind but thank you both for
the moment coming up after the break
more of our press preview including who
has made it on to the King's first
birthday honors list do stay with us
thank you
[Music]
I'm Katie Spencer and I'm Sky news's
arts and entertainment correspondence
when you think of Glastonbury it's marji
one and music they're gonna cross to us
live okay thank you so much Brad Pitt is
now a prolific producer behind the
scenes it's not a mystery to me we
always were capable of doing this oh
they're wonderful children as an
audience who did that
Maverick here on the red carpet I'm so
excited
this is the story of the night it's a
little independent film that could we
take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
nor have I ever struck any woman in my
life there's this illusion of Power are
you feeling well I remember covering the
Oscars and that now Infamous moment the
Will Smith slap nobody could quite
believe that it happened you can tell
from these crowds just how excited some
people are for the return
[Music]
long after the Sex Pistols broke up are
you pleased that you did say yes to the
job I've never regretted it as a team
we've interviewed some of the biggest
stars in the world it can be incredibly
surreal being swept up in their world
but we try to give you an honest sense
of how these people really are okay I'll
talk to you
okay there's no easy goodies there's no
easy baddies I've had a great time here
thank you thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back part two of The Press
preview Zoe and Mary are still with us
uh Zoe the front page of the mirror my
heroes King's first birthday honors list
the mirror saying unlike the gongs Boris
Johnson lavished on Tory cronies and
party get AIDS today's awards are truly
deserved just having a look at the list
the oldest recipient Zoe 106 year old
Joan Willett who's raised money for the
British Heart Foundation the youngest 18
year old Junior J frude getting the same
honor for services to vulnerable
children
I mean if this list had been designed to
embarrass Boris Johnson it couldn't have
been more apropos you know he it's in
such stark contrast to what Johnson did
you know it's not it doesn't kind of
stick within its class it doesn't
reflect people who've done King Charles
a favor although I don't know what such
a favor would look like it shows a real
kind of depth of research it shows a
real respect for civic duty of quite a
modest kind I mean you know it it sort
of reminds you of what public life used
to be like before did the conservatives
went went wild I don't know maybe Mary
will disagree with that Mary
well I just think it is it's the unsung
heroes the community Champions the
Charities that have benefited from so
many of volunteers who've done
incredible things and it is inspiring
the stories really inspiring and what is
lovely is that you have the 18 year old
and you've got the 106 year old which
just shows that you know anybody can
change the country and change their
community at any age and they can
absolutely make a difference to lives
and transform and what's going on in
society around them so we need to talk
more about these stories frankly than
than the political honors because these
are
um so important to creating strong
communities and a strong society and and
I've seen so many of them in the work
with business in the community we we get
businesses to do more work in the
community and and we've just come back
from a day in Sheffield where this week
where you know we saw so many amazing
organizations but as individuals who are
leading those organizations and helping
people supporting people and that's
always the most vulnerable are the ones
that are that are challenged or or is a
really great charity like the British
heart foundation and so we you know we
there's a there's about service and it's
about that volunteering so it's it's
really good to to have this
um and then I would encourage people to
nominate if you know someone who has
done those sort of things do please
nominate
um which you can do via the cabin office
website you can do it via your local
Laurel of tenant or in London there's
Adept a lot of time for each Borough and
but literally recommend people and for
those sorts of honors who have done
amazing things because they absolutely
deserve it and it inspires other people
to to do other things too that that will
transform lives and really help
communities Thrive yeah I we should also
say of course that some MPS have been
have been honored
um in the king's list long-serving Tory
MPS John Barron Bob Blackman both CBE
sir Ben Bradshaw the labor MP as well
who's uh served in Exeter for for many
years
um okay we've got lots more to discuss
uh after the top of the hour but for now
Mary uh and Zoe thank you very much
they're staying with us for another hour
or so right now